ومع استمرار حمله القمع التي يمارسها
النظام الايراني ضد المحتاجين لجا
الاوروبيون الى العقوبات ضد طهران فبعد
ايام على اعلان الاتحاد الاوروبي فرضى
حزمه جديده قريبا على المسؤولين المتورطين
في قمع الاحتجاجات اكدت المانيا اليوم ان
العمل جاري بالفعل على فرض العقوبات خصوصا
على الحرس الثوري لدوره في عمليات قمع
المتظاهرين وهذه العقوبات التي يجري
اعدادها الان لن تكون الاولى منذ لاعب
احتجاجات في ايران حيث فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي نهايه اكتوبر الماضي عقوبات ضد
مسؤولين ايرانيين بينهم قائد شرطه الاخلاق
وكانت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا
لينابير بوك اعلنت الاسبوع الماضي ان
برلين والاتحاد الاوروبي يدرساني ادراج
الحرس الثوري في قوائم الارهاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]